[موسيقى]
لو انا عندي مشكله نفسيه اصلا محتاج اخد
بالي انا نفسي بشكل يمكن اكتر من العادي
شويه في رمضان لو احنا بنتكلم على الحاجات
العاديه زي قله الاكل تغيير في العادات من
ضمن الحاجات اللي بتنفع اول حاجه في رمضان
انا مش صايم لوحدي انا صايم مع كل الناس
اللي حواليا فده يعني احساس بالمشاركه
الحاجه التانيه هو اني افكر نفسي بهدف
الموضوع انا مش بعمل الكلام دهوت من غير
سبب انا بعمل الكلام ده للتقرب من ربنا
بعمل الكلام ده علشان اقدر اكبر وانمو
نفسيا لانه مجرد ان انا اقدر اتخلى عن
شهوات ورغبات حتى اللي فيها طبيعي وعادي
بيادي الى انه قدرتي على التعامل مع
الحياه وصعوبتها عموما بتتحسن فانا
بالتالي افكر نفسي تنظيم اكلي تنظيم
شرب مفيش داعي ان احنا ناكل كتير مثلا
ساعه الفطار
نخلي السحور يكون موجود بشكل منتظم
الرياضه شيء مهم جدا جدا جدا
ما نسيبش الحاجات اللي المفروض بنكون
بنعملها كل يوم يعني مش عشان انا مثلا
تعبان شويه او بتاع اسيب الشغل
ان الشغل ده ممكن تكون حاجه تاخد باقي من
التوتر والقلق اللي عندي وتخليني
مزاجي يبقى احسن
[موسيقى]
وتغيير السيستم زي اللي عندنا بشكل مفاجئ
ممكن تؤدي الى تغييرات فسيولوجيه تؤدي الى
قلق وتوتر زي مثلا
نقص السكر مستوى السكر في الدم فانا لو مش
واكل مستوى السكر في الدم بيقل بيطلع
ادرينالين يؤدي الى
تصارع في ضربات القلب والعرق يمكن ساعات
يزيد شويه
ويعني موقف زي موقف زي مواقف مواجهه الخطر
ده يؤدي الى ساعات ان احنا نفقد اعصابنا
نتعامل مع بعض بشكل غير لائق وانه هو ده
الحاجه اللي احنا يعني المفروض ما نكونش
بنعملها في رمضان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات